claude françois est mort il ya trente
ans l'anniversaire de sa disparition
c'est demain et la légende est encore
très vivace il s'écoule chaque année
près de 200 mille albums du chanteur
la jeune génération lui rend aussi
hommage avec un disque de reprises où
l'on retrouve notamment jeanne cherhal
ou la grande sophie mais en fait claude
françois a été repris dès ses débuts
olivier les nodes à dominique connaît
les filles du c'est méritoire ce parce
que tu crois landais dès ses débuts dès
son premier succès les chanteurs de
l'époque interprété ses tubes à l'image
d'un match où quand il écrivait claude
françois n'obéissez qu'à une seule règle
c'est le mon petit frisson pas de savoir
si c'est si les petits frissons alors je
ne réfléchis pas du monde ça peut plaire
au public ou pas une grande maison au
bout d'une allée
et puis sur la porte une petite pancarte
où l'on a écrit à louer
ils sont entrés en studio c'est rageant
la grande sophie
quand il roulait quand étonné quand il
marche
la nouvelle génération y ça devenait
vite le répertoire de cloclo
mais
je suis
à partir du moment où on l'a décalé on
l'a on aborde différemment
on n'a pas l'impression de voilà on a
l'impression de faire de faire autre
chose c'est une petite larme
une petite perle
meurant d'arrêt dit qu'il la petite
larme chanté par jeanne cherhal je
regrette un peu cette période là en fait
non je la connais pas mais je voulais
j'aimerais bien avoir été une chanteuse
ya trente ans pour moi justement ce côté
car léger
les hommages se multiplient 30 ans
l'anniversaire n'est pas commémorer
uniquement en france ça s'en va et ça
revient ces mêmes parties jusqu'au japon
fitch le lundi au pays du soleil levant